167 years of History over in a single
weekend the emergency sale of Credit
Suisse one of the banking world's
biggest names to fellow Swiss bank UBS
is Raising fresh fears about the state
of the financial system European Central
Bank president Christine Lagarde trying
to inject some calm into a nervy market
Financial tensions
for the last 10 days or so are not
trivial so I'm not you know minimizing
but I'm also saying that we have a
strong banking sector much stronger than
it was during the last great financial
crisis there is now only one big name in
Swiss banking but UBS dropped some heavy
hints that it won't have room for all
its new employees
UBS intends to downsize credit suisse's
Investment Banking business and align it
with our conservative risk culture One
Credit Suisse worker described the mood
in the London office we've disguised
their voice
there's a lot of empty desks I suspect a
lot of people are you know frantically
trying to rush to other employers other
Banks your days definitely feel numbered
there's a lot of anger towards top
management so the actions of a few over
a period of time cost a lot of people
their job
but sadness is the Primary Emotion
and since credit suisses collapse
followed separate crises at Silicon
Valley Bank and other American Banks
some are asking is history repeating
itself experts say no this is not
another 2008 situation we do not have a
massively interconnected banking system
we do not have totally inadequate levels
of capital we're not at the end of a big
bull run in uh Mortgage Debt origination
and underwriting
London has so far avoided most of the
bumps in this roller coaster but no one
here is relaxed
Finance is part of the plumbing that
underlies the economy all of our lives
so while the events in Switzerland and
the US might feel like a long way away
the bank of England it's still concerned
first because while it thinks the
financial system might be in a better
place than it was in 2000 and it is
still a chance that investors might get
spooked second because if banks decide
they don't want to lend out as much then
we have a potential credit crunch with
real economic consequences
some think the bank May pause interest
rate increases even as inflation remains
High
it might seem odd that the fate of
distant Banks is causing Tremors here
but one thing we learned from the last
crisis is when Banks go bad we all fill
the consequences at Conway Sky News